et poursuivant avec notre chef de bureau
emmanuel c'est une rencontre qui semble
avoir été satisfaisante pour les
premiers ministres les premiers nice qui
ont mis qui ont beaucoup souligné
l'importance du changement de ton du
gouvernement fédéral
oui c'était un peu le pari de justin
trudeau dans cette rencontre vous savez
ce une de ses très vieilles promesses
électorales si vous voulez ça fait des
années qu'ils plaident sur toutes les
tribunes au pays qu'il est essentiel de
changer la nature des relations entre
ottawa et les provinces sont parés d'une
certaine façon c'est de changer cette
relation là en est un où les provinces
arrivant devant avec des listes
d'épicerie pour demander de l'argent et
que ottawa se ramasse isolé confronté au
groupe une fois par année
ce qu'il veut mettre en place c'est
vraiment un dialogue entre de part et
d'autre parce qu'il faisait à bout qu'on
verra usage
mais si un peu ce qu'il a réussi
aujourd'hui il était ici il avait pour
mandat je voudrais de rassurer les
provinces sur deux fronts 1 à l'effet
que oui tout le travail que celles ci
ont fait sur le dossier des changements
climatiques que le fédéral allait en
tenir compte et du moins à la veille de
la conférence de paris allait se servir
de ça comme base si vous voulez pour
essayer de redorer l'image du canada
vous savez c'est un enjeu aussi qui est
économique et tout le monde avait
intérêt je vous dirai à être sur la même
page à tenir le même discours à réussir
donc cette idée du canada qui ne parle
que d'une seule voix parce que le canada
une dure leçon il ya quelques semaines à
peine quand les etats unis ont fermé la
porte à kiston en disant que le pétrole
canadien était le plus sale au monde est
là on l'a vu les répercussions
économiques de d'une mauvaise réputation
sur la scène internationale et donc on
veut tirer profit de cette conférence de
paris pour essayer de changer cette
image du canada met d'ailleurs justin
trudeau qui sera accompagné donc par la
plupart de ses premiers ministres sauf
qu emmanuel le plus difficile reste à
faire alors dans les relations fédérales
provinciales dans cette nouvelle ère on
peut la qualifier comme ça de
fédéralisme de coopération
oui le plus difficile reste à faire
d'une part sur les changements
climatiques c'est une chose pour dire
assez bon le travail que vous avez fait
on va partir à paris avec ça maintenant
monsieur trudeau doit présenter des
nouvelles cibles 90 jours après donc
c'est con
l'erreur de paris s'associe aux fleurs
mettre sur la table les plans de toutes
les provinces les évaluer les chiffrer
qu'est ce qu'il va faire qu'est ce que
les provinces on faire si on a une qui
me passait l'épaule à la roue
s'il faut demander à d'autres d'en faire
plus alors que celles-ci jugent qu'elles
ont fait déjà beaucoup et ça c'est sans
compter qu'on va discuter à la prochaine
réunion fédérale-provinciale économie
santé c'est là que les provinces vont
venir cogner à la porte de tahoua et
dire à monsieur trudeau vous avez
première campagne électorale de les
bonifier les transferts en santé de
maintenant il faut commencer à le faire
tout ça dans un contexte où les finances
publiques à ottawa sont encore moins
bonne que ce qu'on avait anticipé
pendant la campagne